The first part of your question,
live streaming is we defined it in first
implemented it back in the mid 19
nineties,
um,
was a time based versus space are
surface based organization of
information.
The idea was that every electronic
assets you had,
every piece of information,
whether it was an email or an instant
message,
whether it was a file or a spreadsheet,
whether it was a photo or an MP3,
would appear in a single time ordered
stream that mirrored the evolution of
your life.
So in principle,
the first thing on the stream would be
my birth certificate and an electronic
version of that.
My parents would put my records,
school records,
health records,
whatever went on that child onto the
stream.
And the Stream is um,
uh,
continues to flow forward through time.
I can deal with the future is available
to me as well as the past.
So I can search in the past,
find what I want.
Everything is fully indexed.
Um,
if,
when I schedule things,
when I know things are coming up,
I put them in the future when I have
something that I need to return to that
I don't have time for now,
I put it in the future.
So,
uh,
and together with that we had an
interface,
we thought it was important not to make
use only of the surface of the screen,
but to uh,
present displays in depth that made use
of the other virtual depth of the
screen.
So I wasn't looking at surface,
I was more looking through a window into
an arbitrarily large information
landscape.
So instead of the mouse just moving a
cursor over the surface,
it would be a robot vehicle moving
through three space or some arbitrary
space.
Um,
but the basic idea was symbol,
just a chronological timeline,
heterogeneous with absolutely everything
on it.
We have seen it a commercialized in two
different ways.
One way,
the one that I'm allowed to talk about
that I no longer own.
These patents,
the patents have changed hands and the
patents are now subject of enormous
lawsuit against Apple,
which is not mine because I don't own
the patent I'm told is the largest
lawsuit in patent history.
Apple took these ideas.
I'm not in a position to say they stole
them,
I don't know if they did or not legally,
but these ideas are the basis of apples,
a cover flow of the way they display,
uh,
originally.
Um,
uh,
songs on itunes cover flow is now become
a standard way of displaying files on
virtually all apple platforms.
Spotlight,
which allows you to find files not by
name or folder,
but by content and time machine,
which is a series of,
of archive things without commenting on
the legal aspects which are not capable
of doing.
Those are,
those are live streams.
And there are other companies that have
done similar things that makes me angry
personally,
obviously the money,
but because of the deliberate failure to
acknowledge work that,
that we would have made freely available
as academics.
And that,
uh,
companies nowadays will not acknowledge
because there's so much money involved.
The same time on the network,
there are thousands of groups that are,
that are building live streams or live
streaming it for themselves in their own
way.
We love to see this activity.
There's a lifestyle blog talking about
all the different life.
So,
so that's,
that's great.
And for that matter we're delighted to
see apple do it too.
Um,
but when there are large companies that
work on it,
which is also the case with,
with friend feed,
um,
with the,
with the event stream on facebook,
uh,
which,
which is true with the aol aol Bebo
Stream,
which they actually call a live stream
or live streaming.
It's not,
it's not as if we want to stop that
activity,
shut it down,
but we'd like to see credit where credit
is due,
not just to me or even me mainly to me,
but to the graduate student actually
built the software,
worked tremendously hard,
published the papers,
put them in,
you know,
made them available.
And uh,
we'd like to see credit.